the Joe Rogan experience when you say
you do other things look what do you
think you'll do when you stop fighting
I'm still passionate about I want to be
a marriage counselor a marriage
counselor that wasn't if I wasn't
fighting that was what I'd be that is
hilarious
yeah me and my wife would see a marriage
can see ya komaru smile what yeah you
see sideline he's got a side gig he's a
marriage counselor yeah I want to be a
magickal why it's just something about
it I'm I was always I think personally I
was always very good at being able to
step back from situations and what's
going on keep a level head and being
able to dissect what's going on and give
it left side and give advice and and and
I do this with my friends where my
friends tell you like think of you boy
tell you a story like yeah my this
happened when my daughter's mom my my
mom my wife or this and that you know
she she came home and she said this and
that and all this in and then she take
me on the house man she's wrong for this
but when they're telling the story and
my I don't know why but in my head how
I'm taking the Denny's he's saying all
she called me a [ __ ] but what did you
say before that that's that's what
that's I surely that goes into my head
what did you say you for that and then
she threw this at me why did she throw
that what did you do what did you say
you know so when everyone tells you a
story when they say there's three sides
to every story there's yours hers and I
literally lit like in my mind that's
what goes on when someone's telling me a
story but do you know how funny it is
that you want to be a marriage counselor
do you understand how crazy that sounds
yeah it does sound weird but the UFC
welterweight champ of the world you got
smash people and I may not be a marriage
counselor okay 106 do you think tomorrow
I want to be a longshoreman want to be a
brain surgeon gonna be a fighter pilot
marriage counselors honesty number 100
I'm like that's definitely not real we
definitely wanna be a [ __ ] in
their marriage counselor that's not real
yeah that that marriage counselor will
be there or just some a counsel of some
sort a counselor yeah you're helping
helping shape and mold well I want to
leave this when I leave this world I
want to leave it better than that when I
came in or when I lived through it I
want to leave it it's better situation
but one thing you can do you have you
could have a tremendous impact on young
people because of what you've
accomplished we've come from how
inspirational you are and then just a
physical difficulties you're dealing
with while you're doing that with your
injuries and all the the preparation
that you have to do to fight for the
title and your honesty about it when
people or a young person hears your
story like that it'll make them think
like with hard work but anything is
possible with the right mindset in the
right discipline almost anything is
possible yes absolutely
anything is possible because um you know
where everybody thinks nowadays all I'm
limited I can't do that because it is I
can't do it because and it's funny
because my daughter sometimes you know
will be she wouldn't work time her you
know her she's one worried there was a
certain point I'm teaching an entire
shoes and she gets to a point where she
can do it she's doing that she didn't
doing it and this show just decide one
day that she doesn't want to do it so
she'll play this game like I can't daddy
I can't do it I'm like why why can't you
do it she's like because I'm four I
can't do it because I'm only four so I
don't know how to do it like well you
did it yesterday right you can do it no
I can't do it I don't know how to do it
and like she mentally she just wants to
feel that she can't do it because
everyone's like oh you're four years old
she knows she's four years old so she
wants to just I'm four so I shouldn't be
able to do I don't want to do it and I'm
like no you can do anything that you
want to do or she'll be outside playing
soccer so I got her into soccer and
she's like no I can't I'm not good I
can't play I can I don't know how to do
it like yeah you can do it no but I
don't I didn't get the ball today I
don't know how to play I'm like you can
do anything you want to do if you put
your mind to it baby you
do anything and it's it's sound and when
I even when I say that to her I'm like
she's only five but if I say it enough
by the time she's ten it's gonna stick
in her mind it's there and so the the
fact that people let go through life
like that now all I can't do it because
I'm not I can't do it I'm not supposed
to do it man young people just feel like
no I shouldn't be able to do it but it's
the matter of putting the work in like
you can't tell somebody like if they do
something well enough over and over and
over and over and over and over
they're not gonna improve mmm even
though you suck you're gonna get good at
sucking at some point like you're gonna
improve and so people just don't want to
try sometimes because they just like I
can't do it
I can't be good enough at that so I
won't do it and I and I learned that
lesson the hard way because when I
started wrestling I used to see there
was this this just poster that ASIC put
out USA rests and they put out this
poster of the best wrestlers in the
country in high school and I remember
the first time I went to farther I was
looking at the poster and he's nerdy
looking kids I mean this one there's
just one kid he was super nerdy
yeah glasses like just like I'm like you
know the kind of kid that you would like
I know kids picked on in my school and
then I I I hear the name I see the name
I read the name and I hear and my god
okay I don't know that is because he's
from his like some other state maybe
like Pennsylvania or something and and
then I could hear through the
loudspeaker they called it like all this
kids wrestling on Matt one so then I
look I'm at one and yeah he looks goofy
goofy-looking kid she walk up to the mat
takes his glasses off puts him down goes
out there and just whips the [ __ ] out of
these other kids like I mean he was
rolling kids up I'm like what what just
happened the rolling kids up and I think
if he can do it and and you know that's
the kind of kid that you would look at
and judge my all man I could bully this
kid I'd be a bad day for a bully
[Applause]